you don't need money to start a business
I got a great question for my YouTube
viewers love you guys
tank wahoo wrote in to say I really want
to open my own vegan bakery slash cafe
the issue here is money and I don't even
know in a kitchen I came up with baking
years ago since my parents wanted me to
become a nurse worst thing I did was
give up on something I believed in and
loved I'm still resentful towards them
although really it was my own fault for
not going with what I wanted this is a
great question and I've got three bits
of advice to help you with this problem
number one is change your mindset you're
telling yourself a story that is holding
you back right now you're blaming your
parents you're blaming them because they
had your best interests in heart they
were looking out for you they wanted you
to be a nurse even though it wasn't your
dream and you listen to them when you
give up control of your life of your
destiny and put it into somebody else's
hands you have nobody to blame but
yourself so stop feeling resentful stop
blaming them start looking in the mirror
and saying this is on me to fix nobody's
going to give you your dream if you want
to chase something it's up to you to
follow it number two is model success if
you went out and took out a loan to
start this business you would fail right
now because you don't know anything
about running a vegan bakery cafe you'll
make a ton of mistakes and you could be
in debt for the rest of your life so
instead of jumping all in goal model
success learn from someone who's already
doing what you want to do go find a cafe
that you look up to that you respect
who's doing exactly what you want to
become and go work for them learn the
ropes understand what makes them
successful get as close to the founder
as possible take on as much roles and
responsibilities as you can you're
getting paid to learn you're getting
paid to make mistakes you're getting
paid to make connections and you're
getting paid to get educated on how to
run a successful bakery number three it
starts small start right now with what
you have you're starting from here we
have this desire to build a bakery your
next step you see is being way up here
where you want to open up your bake shop
and you can't bridge that gap right the
only way you can see it is you have to
get some money you don't have the money
you don't know how to scale that big gap
the way to do it is to take smaller
steps break that down to the next step
to allow you to start making forward
progress
you don't start with a bakery you start
by doing bake sales here's a great
example of a local Toronto and City
vegan bakery cafe called bunner's I
first met the owner actually at a bake
sale in the basement of a church she was
selling gluten-free cupcakes and they
were amazing
she went to bake sale after bake sale
after bake sale learning what works
figuring out who her customers were
understanding what recipes people really
really liked she learned she saved up
she started part-time before jumping all
in when she saved up enough money and
she knew she had customers she can call
on and she knew she had products that
people would actually buy she opened up
her first location then she opened up
another then she started a cookbook then
she started a wholesale business and now
she's winning awards for best new bakery
best dessert shop best muffin vegan or
otherwise so change your beliefs and
stop blaming other people model success
and go work for someone who's doing this
right now
and start small on the side instead of
thinking you have to go all-in and
launch your own shop and continue to
believe for those you're watching like
the video subscribe to the channel see
more just like it
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you soon if you want more entrepreneur
goodness check out the link to my
newsletter below see you there
you